hey what's going on good people of the
internet
i'm dave rubin this is the reuben report
direct message and today is monday
july 12 20 21
uh as a reminder do me a favor subscribe
to our youtube channel
tap that notification bell share these
videos yada yada yada all right we got
four stories for you there is a ton
going on in the world you know i try not
to tweet on the weekends i play around
in the locals community and i share some
food and that kind of stuff
but i usually shut it down on the
weekend so i not paying that much
attention to current events and
everything else
although people are always texting me
about things and everything so it's hard
to really escape
which is why i do that whole august off
the grid thing but a lot
happened over the weekend so we got four
stories for you today
first kamala harris you know this woman
she's that like psychotically cackling
vice president
uh well she had a did an interview where
she's basically now
saying that rural people people who live
in the middle of the country
that they can't find photocopy machines
for their ids so that's why we shouldn't
have voter id laws
these are the same people she is the
same woman
who will tell you that black people in
inner cities
can't get ids so if you're black in an
inner city you can't get an id and
basically when they say rural they mean
white if you're white and then the
middle of the country
you can't photocopy your id i mean the
soft bigotry of low expectations truly
knows no bottom to this pit so we're
gonna hit that then of course the big
story of the day is that there are
massive massive anti-government
anti-communist protests in cuba it's
quite extraordinary we've got some video
and of course we've got some reaction
not only from
our wonderful mainstream media here in
the united states
but you'll see the stark contrast in
responses
by some conservative leaders and some
lefty leaders here
in america and sadly it will not
surprise you
the third story uh yeah the white house
is now officially promoting systemic
racism we know that they've been
pushing it in to the system already
right like even with the covid relief
bill where if you were a black farmer
you were going to get benefits
that a white farmer didn't get because
i'm pretty sure kovid uh
chose who it was going to affect based
on the color of skin well now the white
house is going all in so we've got video
of everyone's favorite
jen sucky uh and finally
cnn have you watched that clown network
uh recently it's it's just
terrible you shouldn't watch it i hope
you don't watch it and if you do watch
it i hope
you've got some vodka with you well they
are really really
uh going all in on attacking
unvaccinated people people who've made a
choice for
themselves and perhaps their their
family and loved ones
and they are ramping the scare tactics
up to like
level bananas so we are going to cover
all of that before i get to it
i want to talk to you guys about bambi
you know when running a business hr
issues can kill you
wrongful termination suits minimum wage
requirements
labor regulations the list goes on and
on and hr managers salaries aren't cheap
at an average
of 70 000 bucks a year bambi spelled
b-a-m-b-e-e
was created specifically for your small
business you can get a dedicated hr
manager craft hr policy
and maintain your compliance all for
just 99
a month with bambi you can transform hr
from your biggest liability to your
greatest strength
your dedicated hr manager is available
by phone email or real-time chat
from onboarding to terminations they
customize your policies to fit your
business and help you manage your
employees day-to-day
all for just 99 a month month to month
no hidden fees cancel any time
if you're like me then i bet you didn't
start your business because you wanted
to spend all of your time on hr
compliance
ain't that the truth let bambi help get
your free
hr audit today uh go to bambi.com
ruben right now to schedule your free hr
audit that's bambi.com
ruben spelled bam to the b-e-e dot com
slash reuben and now back to me okay so
we've got
some video of kamala harris
now this is the cackling woman who was
polling at zero in her own presidential
party primary when
uh she bowed out of the race and then
joe biden or whoever's pulling joe
biden's strings chose her
as the vice president and if you want to
see what the soft bigotry of low
expectations
is here is exhibit a is
agreeing to voter id one of those
compromises that you'd support
i don't think that we should
underestimate what that could mean
because in some people's mind that means
well you're going to have to
um xerox or or
photocopy your idea to send it in to
prove you are who you are
well there are a whole lot of people
especially people who live in rural
communities who don't there's no
kinko's there's no office max near them
people have to understand that when
we're talking about voter id laws
be clear about who you have in mind and
what would be required of them to prove
who they are
of course people have to prove who they
are
but not in a way that makes it them it
almost impossible for them to prove who
they are
god these people never stop
lying they are gaslighting all of
america let's get that exact quote there
at the end of course they have to prove
who they are
but not in a way that makes it almost
impossible
to prove who they are and then her
argument is that if you live in the
rural area let's say you live in montana
or idaho
there's no kinkos near you there's no
staples
you would be unable to get to a
photocopy machine
to prove that your id is yours and
photocopy it then send it to the proper
authorities
to vote uh she then says i don't think
we should underestimate what that would
mean meaning
voter id laws that you'd have to prove
who you are we shouldn't underestimate
what that would mean
that in my humble opinion that would
mean you as a citizen would have to show
an id prove who you are and then you get
one vote
one vote one person let's prove who you
are zippity-dippity right like not that
confusing not really
crazy racist right-wing stuff pretty
standard sort of civil society
you know kind of 101 we have to have
some rules to make sure that we don't
have voter fraud
but the thing is the democrats do want
voter fraud like what could possibly be
any other conclusion than listening to
that and thinking that woman
wants there to be voter for these are
the same people who will tell you i mean
joe biden has said this repeatedly
that black people don't know how to get
an id or don't have the ability to get
an id he also said that black people
don't
can have no ability to get lawyers or
accountants and they're not sure how to
get online
these are the non-racist i mean really
think about what's going on here so on
one hand she's telling you that the
inner city people because when they say
inner city they mean black people so
inner city people can't get an id
and rural people can't photocopy an id
thus we should have no id requirements
when you want to vote
this is gobbly [ __ ] that is designed
to make sure that we don't have any
voter id laws and when she
says it makes it almost impossible to
prove who they are
i really want you to think about this
really think about this
please let me know please join us in our
robust conversations at ruben
report.locals.com
and let me know do you know anyone that
if they had to show an id
or photocopy an id to vote
that that would be almost impossible
it doesn't exist it doesn't exist and i
hearken back to my interview about a
month and a half ago
with former south carolina governor
nikki haley we did it right here in this
very room
who when the democrats in her state were
saying
oh no people can't get id's what are we
going to do she said okay let's put
money for it
let's put money into a program to ensure
that everyone black white gay straight
etc etc
can get a voter id and you know what
happened
12 people took her up on it 12 people in
all of south carolina
so the point is that when you get on a
plane you have to show an id
when you buy a beer you have to show an
id as i said last time i went
mini golfing i had to show an id because
they wanted me to return the golf club
yet for some strange reason i i'll have
to meditate on this
the democrats don't want you to have ids
and not only do they not want you to
have ids or not have to show an id
i guess they want you to have an id to
get on a plane and get a beer right like
they're not complaining about that
but not want you to show an idea to vote
and there might be a reason for that
and we'll all have to think about what
that reason might be but these people
are just ridiculous okay let's move on
to the to the real story of the day
because this is
absolutely extraordinary and and it's
also um i'm feeling very proud of
america
right now because the people that we're
about to show you these are pro-american
people you're going to see american
flags
and people chanting about freedom and
you know why they're doing that
because cuba has a communist regime okay
and these people want to be free right
they don't want to be
under the gun of the government all the
time actually this past weekend i was
in miami and miami obviously has a
tremendous amount of
cuban refugees cuban immigrants and
ironically yesterday i took a very early
flight it was sunday morning i took a
very early
flight from miami back here to la and
i'm in the uber
and the uber drivers most of the uber i
can't say most but a huge percentage it
seems like most of the uber drivers in
miami
are cuban now that might be for good
reason they come to this country to find
freedom and then they have to work
jobs not everyone wants to be an uber
driver but it's a great job to have
so that you can hopefully build a better
life for your family and your children
all that stuff
anyway i'm talking to the uber driver at
like seven in the morning before these
protests were happening as far as i knew
and i don't think
i don't think they had even started yet
and he was going on and on about how
much he loves america
and how much he supported trump and how
he hates biden and a whole bunch of
other stuff
anyway then i get off the plane and then
i'm seeing all these videos
of what's going on in cuba so first
we're going to show you a quick
compilation about 40 seconds of three
different videos
about what's happening in cuba right
this very moment
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
okay so there's obviously many many more
videos like that there's tons of videos
with american flags and people chanting
free
they want freedom they want liberty all
of those things it will
not surprise you that so far the message
out of our administration joe biden
tweeted something and then saki said
something
that basically these protests are
because of covet lockdowns and
and not being able to get enough
vaccines yes i am not making that up
that's what biden's
tweet basically said it is complete
nonsense that is not why these people
are out on the street
that might be five percent of it that
they're not happy with whatever the
communist regime is doing related to
lockdowns and vaccines and everything
else
these are people who want to be free you
know that thing that most likely if
you're watching this show that you have
that they don't have in places like cuba
and places like venezuela in places
like north korea that's the thing that
they want the thing that we so take for
granted
so of course our administration is
giving a very confusing and muddled
message
because the administration in effect
because
clearly biden whoever is running the
biden show
saki all of the democrats at this point
because they
obviously have leanings that are in kind
with the socialists with the communists
they like that stuff that's the stuff
they're ushering
in here they don't want to come out as
anti-communists right so the messaging
is very confusing
these aren't pro-capitalists or
pro-america or pro-freedom
uh rallies these are actually rallies
because of covid vaccines like it's such
extraordinary nonsense
absolutely extraordinary uh so we've got
a couple tweets here we picked three
people
uh they happen to all be florida people
because there are so many cuban
immigrants in florida so i thought this
would be interesting so first this is
from senator marco rubio
who is his family is from cuba he often
tells the story
of his parents as first generation
immigrants protests in cuba isn't simply
about
shortages socialism promises guaranteed
food medicine and income if you give up
your
freedom when as always it fails to
deliver
you don't get your freedom back that's
why protesters are chanting
libertad and then he has the couple
hashtags there that people are using on
twitter
then from governor of florida ron
desantis
florida supports the people of cuba as
they take to the streets against the
tyrannical regime in havana
the cuban dictatorship has repressed the
people of cuba for decades
and is now trying to silence those who
have the courage to speak out
against its disastrous policies
and then finally this is miami mayor
francis suarez who you may
remember i interviewed a few weeks ago
in miami his father
was the mayor of miami and now he's the
mayor of miami his father
from cuba i believe francis was you know
francis was
was born in miami for sure he said the
cuban regime's military police are
shooting at unarmed cuban protesters
fighting for freedom
60 years of communism cruelty and
oppression
cannot last any longer we are imploring
the usa
to take action as we peacefully
demonstrate on the streets of miami
so that's some of the messages all three
of them obviously are republicans
from california as i said uh because of
the location
of south florida to cuba uh there are
tremendous amount of cubans
in in miami and in florida more broadly
and if you just want to meet a group of
people who love
freedom who love america and all of
those things
then you should meet some cuban
americans because they're a great
example of what the american dream
absolutely is
now i will read some tweets about what's
happening in cuba
from aoc ilhan omar and bernie sanders
oh wait there are none
there are zero tweets from aoc ilhan
omar
and bernie sanders and a bunch of the
other ones from the hamas caucus
and the point is and the reason is that
there are no tweets from them
as i said is because they actually
support the regime
they want the united states to be
more of a communist socialist
dictatorship they want
the government to have all of the power
so they don't want to
promote anything that might show people
yearning for freedom
and yelling about liberty and showing
the american flag because it's the
antithesis
of everything they believe so really
think about what's going on right now
like again you know as i always talk
about we all have friends that are on
the fence about these things a little
bit
unclear about what you know the truth is
what the what the real message of what's
happening
in the day is and it's like this is a
pretty great example those people want
freedom who's standing up for the
freedom well
i just mentioned the florida senator
marco rubio the florida governor
ron desantis and the miami mayor francis
suarez
one of them or two of them happened to
be cuban originally you know
so it's like you see you see what's
happening here and then nothing
nothing from aoc ohan and bernie sort of
like the first story
meditate on that i will uh all right
let's uh jump
back into america for a moment so you
guys know i love this gen
saki this is a woman who's just her
ability to lie
it's like you gotta kind of admire it
it's like wow you
say a lot of nothing and when you do
rarely say something it's a lie and she
mumbles and stammers through almost
everything she says
and now she's basically admitting that
the united states is going to go all
in on critical race theory because of
systemic racism
here's sucky delegates to the national
education association they approved a
measure last week calling for support of
quote
implementation of culturally responsive
education
critical race theory and ethnic studies
curriculum in pre-k through 12
and higher education president is
obviously a big fan of education
first lady is a teacher she's a union
teacher
i'm wondering what are the president's
thoughts on anti-racism curriculum
in the classroom the president believes
that in our history
there are many dark moments and there is
not just
slavery and racism in our history there
are systemic racism
that is still impacting society today
and he believes as i believe
as a parent of children that kids should
learn about our history
uh so as a the spouse of an educator and
as somebody who is
continues to believe that children
should learn
not just the good but also the
challenging in our history and that's
part of what we're talking about here
even as it's become politically
charged okay jen you're lying as usual
here we go let me unpack it so first off
nobody's saying we can't teach the dark
moments
literally nobody is saying it i have not
heard one person
that has any credibility anywhere saying
that we can't teach about the dark
moments of our history that we're not
allowed to teach
about slavery that we're not allowed to
teach about japanese internment
or any other negative thing that the
united states
has done given give an honest assessment
of our founding
no one's saying it well you guys are
saying it but nobody else is arguing
that these things should not be taught
and i'm going to go out on a limb here
and guess that all of you watching this
right now if you went to school in
america whether you went to private
school or public school you learned a
little something
about slavery you learned a little
something about the civil war the
revolutionary war you learned a little
something about our history and it
didn't just say oh america's fantastic
there was no such thing as slavery
everybody's got a great note and it's
always been that way right like this is
just
absolute uh nonsense then she says kids
should learn about our history
yes so we all agree with that no one's
saying that you can't teach the dark
moments and everyone's saying you should
learn about history but what she's
saying is yes we are going to
usher in critical race theory and teach
everyone about systemic racism now for
the billionth time i know they love to
play semantic games
but systemic racism meaning if there was
racism in the system if there were laws
that
favored one race over another that would
be systemic racism and i would be
completely against it okay
if you said oh if you're black you get
this and you're white you get this we
got a systemically racist problem but we
got to get rid of it
in the times in america where there have
been things like that so like jim crow
laws
we have gotten rid of those things we
fought a civil war to get rid of them
etcetera etcetera and in more modern
times
you know in the 80s in new york city
there were laws that i think you could
argue were systemically racist for
example
if you were arrested for smoking crack
which generally was happening in the
inner city by black people
the penalties were higher than say if
you were arrested
for snorting cocaine which was happening
down on wall street mostly with white
people
and there was a disparity in what was
going on in terms of the sentencing
we got rid of that okay so absolutely we
can
we can acknowledge that there have been
laws that have been misguided and all
of that stuff and by the way if you
brought cases forward
where there were still people in jail
for x while someone else was in jail for
why
when it should have been similar
sentencing and they weren't we could
talk about that oh and there was a guy
an orange guy what was the orange guy's
name again trump
there was this guy this orange man named
trump you may remember him he's not on
social media anymore
he was trying to do all of this stuff
right he was trying to do this all
with uh prison reform and he was
actually doing it despite
the best efforts and he was getting the
best efforts of the democrats and he was
getting
low-level often marijuana offenders who
were disproportionately black
be taken out of jail that's what he was
doing but okay i know we don't want to
talk about that
but in essence you're saying okay
systemic racism
is real now this is not a phrase that
joe biden ever said
in his first 47 years of being in public
office
that that's a little odd he just
completely forgot to say
anything about it and then joe biden was
also vice president
under a black president uh barack obama
right right and uh didn't do anything
about systemic racism apparently but
now it's 78 years old and potentially
with dementia oh and by the way
uh i'm not going to say that joe biden
has dementia anymore because you know
i've said it i can't
fully diagnose him with dementia and my
sister said to me
you know you say he has dimension i
usually say i'm not diagnosing him but
it's like you know it's
sort of like an amorphous term like
something ain't right with this guy so
i'm gonna say for now on the joe biden
has ops
uh this is old person syndrome i think
that would be a better way of describing
what's going on
with joe biden he has o p s o person
syndrome
so he forgot to tell barack obama about
the systemic racism
you know that he was dealing with in
those 47 years uh
and then barack you know barack forgot
to do anything about it himself
and here we are so these people are
absolutely ridiculous
but if you think that this thing isn't
all tied together and how the unions are
involved in everything else you may
remember on friday
we played this video of randy weingarten
who's the president
of the largest teachers union and if you
want to listen to somebody speaking out
of both sides of their mouth
i present you randy weingarten
critical race theory is not
taught in elementary schools or middle
schools
or high schools it's a method
of examination taught in law school
and in college that helps analyze
whether systemic racism exists
and in particular whether it has an
effect
on law and public policy
but cultural warriors are labeling
any discussion of race
racism or discrimination scrt
to try to make it toxic they are
bullying teachers
and trying to stop us from teaching
students accurate history okay so this
woman i mean this is sake level lying so
on one hand she's saying it's not being
taught now we know
it is being taught right we've given you
plenty of examples here
but just in the last couple days chris
ruffo i mentioned him on the show weekly
at this point
uh who's doing the greatest work when it
comes to exposing this nonsense
he found a list of 30 school districts
in america that are
teaching it right now by their own
doctrines right by their own documents
that they use to teach
at least 30 school districts that are
now teaching this stuff
in k-12 so on one hand she's saying it's
not being taught and then if you listen
to the last sentence there she's saying
but
you know it is an honest assessment of
what's going on in the world and it's an
honest assessment of our history
well if that's what you believe lady
then why wouldn't you be teaching it
so everything that these people say is
just
complete nonsense and as i often say
we've got our work cut out for us
let's do one more for you today cnn
which is a i suppose it's a news network
of some sort it's a
it's a fun place run by democrats like
don lemon
and chris cuomo and jake tapper and wolf
blitzer and jim acosta or any of these
people not obviously democrats or any of
these people
obviously not progressives i mean they
all are but they pretend to be
an unbiased news network now you might
say dave but you
tell people about the news you read
stories and share your opinion
and yes i do and i think you fairly well
know my opinion and who i voted for and
why i voted and
what my biases are and perhaps what my
blind spots might be this is
a wonderful thing that we're doing here
that i think is you know ballpark
honest let's put it that way right like
you know what i you know what i think
i really think you you know as much
about what i think about the world
pretty much as i do i really believe
that uh because i'm just telling you
what i think here right and then i can
you can match that up with your own
reality and figure out what's what well
cnn pretends
that it's a news network an unbiased
news network but it's not it's it's a
propaganda wing of the democrat party
and they are really not happy that a
certain amount of americans are not
getting
vaccinated right now again you make a
decision for yourself
masks you know my feelings about all of
this stuff okay and we know
again that 97 to 99.5
roughly a percentage of people who got
kovid
survived kovid the people who did not
survive had co-morbidities
diabetes cancer heart disease a series
of other things
but they really really want you to get
vaccinated on cnn
i'm not exactly sure why i don't want to
be a conspiracy theorist here but we've
got two videos for you we'll
we'll show one this is dr jonathan
reiner on cnn
talking about mandating vaccines
i do think it's time to start mandating
vaccines and i think that private
industry and private organizations will
do that
you know at gw university where i work
uh starting
uh this fall you can't be on campus
unless you're fully vaccinated
look i think that we're in the part of
the pandemic now where
the the problem in this country is that
150 million americans are not vaccinated
now half of that uh number is uh
less than 18 years of age but let's look
at the adults 75 million adults have
chosen not to get vaccinated
and that choice has consequences now we
can't force you to take a jab in the arm
but there are many jobs perhaps that can
prevent you from working if you decide
not to get vaccinated
so i think we need to be more proactive
and i think we will see
uh industry take the lead in this
i mean that should chill it should send
a chill down your spine the
authoritarianism that sits right behind
someone who purports to be a medical
doctor so he's saying 150 million people
aren't vaccinated 75 million of them are
americans and then basically he's
talking about
what the repercussions are if you don't
get vaccinated but notice he didn't
mention the medical repercussions
because he knows if he was to say what
the medical repercussions are if you
don't get vaccinated and by the way i'm
not giving you medical advice
i'm telling you to do what you think you
should do and talk to your doctor about
it
and that's what and that's what you
should do right who am i to tell you
what to do and
who's this tv doctor to tell you what to
do but notice when he says well 75
million americans haven't gotten it
meaning million
adults now the kids it's interesting
because he's saying 75 million kids
haven't got he kind of threw that number
away
he's coming for the kids like they're
obviously coming to
to have men vaccine mandates for the
kids for sure but just dealing with
those americans notice when he's talking
about the repercussions
his repercussions are you shouldn't be
able to go to work something to that
effect he doesn't say what the
repercussions are if you got covered
because if you got coveted most likely
you would then have the antibodies you
would survive and if you didn't have
comorbidities and you weren't of a
certain age and everything else
you would be just fine after that's the
truth
that's the truth but he really really
wants you know where he goes to work at
gw
they're gonna mandate it and that we
should really encourage
other private businesses because maybe
it's unconstitutional
because of right to privacy and all that
maybe it's unconstitutional for the
government to do it so maybe we should
have
private enterprise do it this by the way
is very similar to
when you know people want twitter and
youtube and everybody else the big tech
guys
to crack down on your speech the
government can't quite do it right
you may remember that moment with aoc at
one of the hearings when she was
basically
saying that to zuckerberg hey we can't
do it so why don't you do it which is
the worst sort of
government coercion there is so these
are these are not good people
then we've got video more from cnn the
democratic
operatives at cnn this is former planned
parenthood president
and current cnn medical contributor
leanna when
for more on vaccines i think this really
depends on
what it is that we do at this point so
now we have this delta variant that is
much more contagious
because it's more contagious it's going
to be even harder for us to reach herd
immunity we're going to have to
vaccinate
an even higher proportion of people to
get there what happens then if we end up
having
another variant developing that's even
more contagious that could cause more
disease that could evade the protection
of our immune
system and so how quickly we get this
under control and which way
we go depends on what we do now when it
comes to vaccination
to overcoming disinformation and what we
really need to do at this point is to
make vaccination
the easy choice it needs to be hard for
people to remain unvaccinated
right now it's kind of the opposite it's
fine i mean it's easy if you're
unvaccinated you can do everything you
want to do anyway
but at some point these mandates by
workplaces fight schools
i think it will be important to say hey
you can opt out but if you want to opt
out
you have to sign these forms you have to
get twice weekly testing
basically we need to make getting
vaccinated the easy choice that is what
it's going to take for us to actually
end the pandemic
yeah she's evil can you get me the
numbers on how many uh
babies planned parenthood is killed uh
last i don't know give me give me some
numbers on that we'll get some numbers
on that in just a second
i say that as someone that is
begrudgingly pro-choice as i described
in my book if you want more of my
feelings on that
um but she wants to really make this
impossible for you to make a medical
decision for yourself uh we she then of
course brings up the delta variant and
guess what there's going to be an omega
variant
and there's going to be another variant
after that and another one after that
and everything else and then we're gonna
have you're gonna have to sign papers
right we're gonna have to show me your
papers
you have to sign papers we're gonna have
to perhaps put you in camps maybe we
should give you special
showers with certain chemicals in those
showers
i mean this all sounds nuts but we are
in a dystopian future and we are in it
right now
and it is a confluence of our corporate
media
our completely psychotic out of control
democrat party
rid uh you know which is led by a man
with ops old person syndrome
and then these these doctors that get on
all of these shows
who clearly got nothing right if any of
these doctors got anything right
in the last year and a half then
wouldn't everything be just fine right
now
two weeks to flatten the curve i mean i
say it all the time guys but we all did
it
we all did it and we gave them more than
two weeks and we were all washing our
garb you know our
our bags are when we went to the grocery
stores
we all did everything that they asked
everyone did
and also can someone explain to me why
one of the states that
opened up didn't collapse why didn't
florida or texas or tennessee collapse
and why wasn't new york or california or
michigan perfectly inoculated
why are the numbers ballpark even
remotely the same and in most cases
they're better in the red states
but if they did completely different
policies
related to all of this why were the
numbers even remotely the same right
none of it makes sense why is it that
not one country somewhere perhaps in
africa that didn't have
the technology or the wherewithal or the
information to deal with this thing
properly why did not one country fail
why didn't we find one city
that was completely infected and
everyone died all of this stuff like i'm
just asking questions here okay
i don't mean to be a crazy right-wing
conspiracy theorist when i say all this
i'm just asking the questions
but we didn't uh let's see um
planned parenthood performed 354
000 abortions in 2019 according
to live action what was that it was
around it's around a thousand a day
roughly
so that's about a thousand abortions a
day i only bring this up because this
woman is
very very concerned about you she ran
planned parenthood they did a thousand
abortions
a day she's very concerned about your
health uh as for
the health of those babies i guess
perhaps not as much
um all right guys i feel like this was a
chock full of information show for a
monday morning in the summer we're we're
rolling right into the summer
uh as i told you guys last week i have
made my plans for off the grid we're
we're actually setting up a couple shows
that we're going to post in august
that are going to all be about sort of
relaxing and getting away from some of
this nonsense and everything else
so we're not going to bludgeon you with
content in august because i want
everybody to kind of calm down
if you haven't seen it yet part one of
my interview
uh with minority leader of the house
kevin mccarthy
is up right now and it's a really
interesting interview we did it we did
it live in studio a couple days ago
and it's really really interesting
because he's got an interesting take you
know he was sort of in the trump camp
then not in the trump camp he's trying
to figure out what the future
of the gop is he he actually
teases some really interesting
interesting information
about sort of the radical wing of the
democrats versus the old
school wing and what really the inner
workings are right there so it's almost
in some ways like there are four parties
in america but we're just pretending
there's two
they're sort of the radical lefty
socialists that have basically overtaken
the democrats with a couple
moderates there and then what is the
future of the republican party is it the
trump party
or is it more of the traditional
republican party and i think he's one of
the guys trying to balance that thing
out figure out what it is
you know i have my feelings on it he is
his all good if you want to talk to me
personally people we just found out that
june was
our biggest month of growth ever at
reubenreport.locals.com
and there's just tremendous stuff going
on with locals right now
and i've been hinting more of it within
the community but that's why i was in
miami there's
just a lot of good stuff going on and we
will build
other people will burn we will build i
hope you will join us in the building
process
have a great monday everybody we'll see
you tomorrow